为什么我们学了很多知识但赚不到钱啊
因为我没有自己的系统
所以今天的条内容的话呢
他
不是那么容易
而且
很难理解
他其实是我们今天
内部会议两个小时
分享完了以后好的老会就说
越来太复杂了
所以我今天拍一条视频吧
就是几分钟的视频
把整个的内容打在一个概括
先说清楚
这条视频是告诉你该学什么的
你们见过那个
我以后要往家入那个
洪滑会吧
陈敬男的时候给一个不我们几一陈敬的话
一对
说这要学所有东西吗
陈敬男说这只是
这只是目入
我今天给大家分享的是你要学什么东西
这是
狂价最重要的东西
然后你该怎么做
他其实主要的结构是什么
就是
我说低你要去哪
你是谁你要去哪
你该怎么去其实这么的东西
气统是非常重要
他要三个部分组成了
今天的话要三个部分组成第一部分就是
你要理解
外面的世界
是什么样子的
如果你对这个实的理解是正确的
你都一定有你想要的东西
如果没有
对不起你理解的世界和真实的世界
有一个断层
就因为这个断层
你会发现你的生活状态是不顺成的
我看好多老会就说你一会头会怎么了
要替组出家呢不是
因为我有点高血压
我想把它根治了
对对对他上没有
要去辅药
我还准备货很长时间
因为
我可能
最近你年才真正要理解这个世界是什么地方的
所以我就跟好的活下去
所以跟放心
来
那么
怎么去理解这个世界有哪些关系的知识要学习
我给大家得出几个关系的知识
首先第一个关系的知识
就是你要去学习
经历学
因为我们现在所处的
这样一个大会经历就是市场经历学
他是我们这个市场运转的规律
就你一看
他为什么会这样
他为什么能赚钱为什么是这样的
这个就是
市场的规律是让你运动
少年你运动来解释的事情
解释规律吗
发责吗
对吧
第二个是什么呢
第二个是行就是你要学行为心理学
行为心理学干嘛呢
我说多少商业的东西
就是你能看明白人家为什么会买单
为什么不买单
人家为什么会
会有这样一个角错
这个东西明明很贵他为什么买
这个东西很便宜为什么他不买
对不对
这个叫行为心理学
这两个是很重要的商业模式
有的这两个你觉得看明白
哦这个公司靠什么东西
千充哪海的
为什么能吃一颗
那么第三个很重要的那种叫什么
就你要学习学会做绝策
选择大运动力
所以一定要学会做绝策
那绝会做绝策
你要去早相关的书记
对吧
你比如说你前面那个你要学
什么费办的经济学院里
对吧
那个行为经济学你可能要学什么影响力呀
这个
是会认为学
对吧
那你绝策的话那你可能要学
我到底怎么做绝策
有装面绝策的书啊
到底怎么做绝策
这样你才知道该怎么做选择
选择很重要的
你像我原来是学途目的嘛
对吧
后来我自己学变成
就这种后来往实在
然后现在开始做
这个
自媒体投资
AI对吧
其实
我们并不给人聪明
但是有一点是什么的
就是我选了一个好的材料
就是咱俩能力差不多
甚至我能力还不如你
但对不起
我做电梯上来的
你做楼心上来的
就选择吧
对不对
所以你回发一下
十分钟以后跑的
我跑多点了
或者跑得失成了
你还在三川楼跑呢
这个不是说能力怎么样
对吧
那么就是因为我做电梯的
就你们说的勾势院
但这个勾势院就选择
选择时候方法的
对吧
所以你学会选择
还有一个很重要的
叫戴律
就该联论啊
这个世界有很得东西
他
他不是说你一定能成的
他是要有戴律的
所以我一直给他讲
戴律是要好好学习的
到底怎么
你要学会利用戴律
让自己活生
有的时候不是一定我们就能成功的
我之前刚才大家说成功的
什么
等于你的
命中御成为出手的次数成为
是吧
成为戴律
所以戴律是一定要学学的
这四个
除了大概以后
前两个告诉你这个市场是怎么运本的
这个杀一模是什么
前从哪来
人家为什么没买单
前两个
后两个告诉你怎么去做选择
你到底该怎么行动
所以这第一个
你要看到这个世界是什么
这四个学科
是你要
不于你也不用学的多深
但是你要去了解
没事就花点深就了解
这样让你理解这个世界
刚才我说了
如果你对这个世界的了解是正确的
那你都一定有
你想要的
如果没有
去许愿
这是第一个
认识这个世界
你别
别带了一模黑的吧
你拿了个恰地图
在家庭上去走
这就很善悔
我们很多人手里拿的这个恰地图
好 我让我们讲
我们讲第二个文字
第二个文字
你要去思考
你要怎么去思考
思考很重要
对了
思在行之前
我们先讲思在两行
所以要许为思考
我跟讲你只要会思考
你只要愿意思考你生活就不会太差
为什么
因为我们身边百分之九的人是不思考的
你自己想想
遇到问题你的第一想法是什么
问个谁
把我出过主意
你想一想
反而是
愿意思考的
主动思考的人其实都能获得不错的
这个收益
对吧
所以思考这个事很重要
我记得是谁说的一会
就好准备的不思考
他你愿意做任何事
所以如果你能思考的话
那你就可以这样
怎么从这个事
这个话我看真不是胡说八道
对吧
就画什么叫
就像不说了
哈哈哈哈你的下面
这个
但是你思考怎么能保证还是正确的
飞机失失了有个黑侠怎么
当时做这个什么错的选择
然后去重够
复盘哪出了错误该怎么去调整
对不对
那我们出错了以后
我是不想复盘啊
所以你要有一个远认知什么的远认知
看自己怎么思考
思考我是怎么思考的
然后我思考的过程中有那些问题
我不断的调整我不断的复盘
我不断的升级
哎这个时候你交有什么好充啊
成功到你命中于成为出手的四属成为改率
就我们好的人干嘛呢就是
失败了以后不总结不反思
所以每次
掉了通过差派多
都还得关于你起这是运气的问题
但是善于思考的人他会总结
哦这个地方可能是个坑
我要注意一些什么东西
我怎么做可能的一种好
他
成功的改率换句话说命中于就会给人
所以他的改率也比较高
所以思考怎么思考的这个事情
他是他是不是要注意啊所以学习一下怎么思考吧
对吧找一些相关的事情如何成为一名聪明
啊别书都有啊怎么思考都有的
包括我自己看思考话一慢自别书
我看的不是他最后得出来觉得我是看他怎么得出那个结论的
就是我不是看他那个
知识我是看他怎么
得出那个知识他思考的过程这是这俩的过程思考
请你记住这句话
这个世界百分之九就认识不思考
你当然大家会思考一点
你都不太一样
好我们说第三个不能到底该怎么行动
就是里面他是有很多罢了我们很决心动会遇到一个问题
我给大家说最大的问题是什么
就是你我们很多人做个事希望马上有结果
我干了一个月为什么没结果
我干了两个月为什么没结果
下啥
下方下的共产党大工
纪假儿
我的干了一个月来你会发工资
两个月了你为什么会发工资
这也都叫纪假儿思维
打工思维
所以我们很难还是用打工思维来这个来这个世界
闯当的
有些事情做事情
不要用纪假儿思维
如果你用纪假儿思维对不起
你是很难真的变得富有的
因为你都是按纪假儿思维的
真正要做的事情是什么
它是要指殊性的
就是你可能干一个月可能干两个月它没结果
但是你突然在第五个月或者第六个月
或者一年以后突然爆发了那个爆发是指殊性的
对吧比如说我给大家一起不小了一座
你可能比如说你可能拍短视频吧
我就我了一座你拍短视频
投资不好想就像短视频吧
你可能比如说你刚开始投一个月
你又不会又没有风格
你也不知道怎么出现
你拍了我就跟狗寺一样
你画的时间也还会怎么拍短视频
内容我会了
水平会的提升了
然后出现你会了就在提升了
在这个过程中你会发现你那个能力都没有
就是指数 等于数都不会太多的别话
但是你在里面掌握了你怎么显然的内容
怎么思考的内容
然后怎么出境内容
当这些期待一块的时候
突然有一天都流染了
那一来就是几十万流染上百万流染
对不对
所以我跟大家讲
一开始不要有太强的多实心
不要太强的多实心
干什么我干了一个月
还没结果
干了两个月还没结果
你那是打工思维
要计较儿子维
你要老有这四个的话你接在做准码去吧
更好的方法应该是什么
我人以为我自己失败
但是失败了以后可不成白失败
为什么失败了
失败了以后有反归的
这里面有个八个
我需要補什么技能
在我的这个地方有一个技能
这有一个技能
对吧
它是成长行思维的
我的能力是成长行思维的
干嘛
你在不断的生金的操作系统
当你的操作系统
高的时候
然后突然一个爆发
所以我的建议是什么呢
你应该有一个长期稳定的收益
但供应应用的生活就好了
然后你的更多的实验
每天要抽出应用的实验来
做过当自己只数一成长的长事
干嘛
三花二二
第一个就是你的实验
你的一节的这个世界
或者政治世界
哪一个真的地图
世界地图
怎么你的这个世界
对吧
经语
行为心理学
这是告诉你
为什么这种的之前
它为什么这个山特运行
前总从哪来
为什么能一直来
怎么做角色
我的选择要到这种角色
概率
就是我知道原来做事是概率的方式
怎么用概率的方式去做选择
这是第一个
第二个就是考
一定要许为实验
这个世界百分之九的人
是不思考的
你思考就不太一样
劳心作人
只能劳力者至于远
是任意色吧
然后怎么思考
思考思考的过程
任意者
这个是要练习
不断的去
而我是怎么思考
就是第二个
我这么思的
第三个形
就是不要
不要太有利益
多是
不要用那么机架
我干了一个月干了
就怎么结果了
你要用指数品种子的
尤其在你的第二许件里
在你能够
我维持自己生活的第二句件里
你要不断的厂势
这种厂势是什么
就是你会发现
我一旦我的投入很少
但是我一旦带来收尼的话
我的收尼会很高
所以每十万一次都要去总结
把它变成主技能
安装到你的操作系统
你干了操作系统
不断的收集
所以各位
专前
不是要靠一个两个只是
而是靠你的系统
你要不断的
收集你的操作系统